Ok, Neptunium is the first of the synthetically-prepared
heavy elements,
Uranium being the last naturally-occurring
element. Neptunium is, as you
might imagine, named after the planet Neptune.
The naming of elements is bizarre to say the
least: sometimes it’s who
discovered it; sometimes it’s where it was
discovered. It has to go to an
IUPAC naming committee and there’s various,
sort of, rules and
regulations which come into it.
Synthetics; what do you mean by synthetic
anyway? What is all that
about?
Synthetic in the sense that it doesn’t naturally
occur on earth, we’ve had
to prepare it by taking other heavy elements
then bombarding them with
various nuclei. Now what happens when you
are bombarding nuclei with
another nuclei is that some bits may stick
and some bits will fall out, but
what you end up with is then a new element-type.
So from here onwards
everything has been man-made, none of it naturally
occurs, unless you
count ‘naturally-occurring’ as being found
in the debris of an exploded
nuclear bomb.